[Music]
well it contributes to the overall
collective security and so being able to
trade with air missile defense but when
you look at all of the warfighting
functions
that when you build this readiness it's
critical to the really our collective
security requirements for the alliance
and absolutely this underpins our
strategy and what we contribute and what
for the article 5 requirement
of course we are extremely concerned of
course the war itself or the the
possibility of war in the 21st century
shocked the whole world shock europe and
and also it touched estonia however i
want to stress that we have had always a
very pragmatic and very clear view on
the russian abilities and capabilities
and the willingness to attack their
neighbors without any cause and reason
so
it
doesn't have anything in common with the
entire context that
we cope with uh
nowadays in this region
uh this is an exercise it's a big annual
exercise
and uh nine meg brigade
mauritius
is playing
twice per year
it is an exercise between my brigade and
u.s soldiers that are deployed to mk
the scenario is 100
percent
fiction
and it's
100 percent defensive
oh this exercise has been a great
learning experience we had the
opportunity to come together and work
with romanian tanks
romanian btrs and their their dismount
soldiers as well as other elements from
the us army who we don't always work
with
and so we've had
we've learned a lot during this time
really the experience to work with the
tanks and with the romanian soldiers was
very helpful
it was a great time we learned a lot
about their different weapon systems or
different capabilities and it showed us
how we can all work together to make a
stronger alliance